and now to the 8 news now investigators
who have an exclusive look at the events
that led to a Clark County District
Court Judge getting arrested on domestic
violence charges she is still sitting on
the bench sometimes even sentencing
people who are charged with similar
crimes our investigator Kyle Payne now
with more
Thursday 2022
by no means a Hallmark holiday for Clark
County District Court Judge Jasmine
Lilly spells
who's tussled with her husband seen here
on his cell phone video excuse me what
obtained exclusively by 8 news now I
need my pack station back you just got
so out of hand
it is she ended up being charged with
misdemeanor domestic battery I'm heading
off to spend the night in jail
you just slim here's an unedited portion
of that altercation look at my other
PlayStation where you can see judge
Lilly spells making a move toward her
husband
the Henderson police report says that
Lily spells went after her husband and
his two PlayStations with this yellow
and black screwdriver
but pictures from the scene show one
PlayStation intact and the other was
hard to find I don't know if it might be
under the pile of clothing Lily spells
would not cooperate with the police
investigation
and told the cops she didn't want her
husband in the house I own the home and
I'm not consenting to any entry into my
home all the while police detaining both
Lily spells and her husband of 13 years
as day
turned in tonight
but before long
behind the bench so what is your true
full name presiding over criminal cases
have you gone over a copy of the
information charging you with battery
concentrating domestic violence of
defendants charged with crimes quite
similar to the domestic violence charge
against her how do you play to this
charge that defendant said he wants to
take his case to trial as for judge
Lilly spells she had her case here at
Henderson Municipal Court honorably
discharged after she completed community
service and anger management counseling
but that might not be the end of the
story it's certainly possible that there
could be more Fallout Professor Benjamin
Edwards teaches ethics to law students
at UNLV ultimately judges or people too
and the kinds of problems ordinary
people have in their personal lives some
judges will
will encounter difficulties there as
well take the case of attorney Anthony
apatangelo he was elected judge at Las
Vegas Justice Court in 1993 and a
misdemeanor domestic violence conviction
in 2009 led to the Nevada Commission on
judicial discipline penalizing him and
he had to agree not to run for judge for
another four years he's in private
practice today the commission wouldn't
confirm or deny an investigation into
judge Lilly spells but told the 8 news
now investigators that in general that
process can take up to a year and a half
I'd say it's fairly unusual so unusual
the Henderson Police couldn't stop
talking about it the night of the arrest
suspect is a judge for the district
court down in Vegas now you know if you
want to come out I've never been to a
judging house in my life I don't know
what the hell is going on
oh see I've never even seen one before
the police had no choice but to arrest
Lily spells if according to Nevada state
statute they think a battery was
committed and testimony and this cell
phone video convinced them don't test me
oh my gosh even despite
the wheels of Justice took this judge to
jail possibly putting her position as
judge in Jeopardy Kyle Payne eight news
now